if there's a lesson to be learned from
Batgirl it might be that no property is
safe from the whims of Studios even a
proven multimedia franchise like Batman
Batman speaking
Warner Brothers Discovery dropped 90
million dollars to bring back girl to
movie screens it was loaded with Talent
including Leslie Grace as Barbara Gordon
JK Simmons as her dad Commissioner James
Gordon Brennan Fraser as the villain
Firefly and Michael Keaton who reprized
his role as Batman with Adele larby and
Bilal fala behind the camera it seemed
at least on paper that Batgirl was
headed for Blockbuster status but
something went wrong Warner Brothers
Discovery canceled plans to release the
film to theaters or even broadcasted on
Max given that Batgirl was still in
post-production at the time of the
decision no official reason was given
for the move though industry experts
have pointed to several allegedly
negative test screenings and the
potential tax write-off for wbd to drop
the expensive project there are
currently no plans to release Batgirl to
any platform